on la croyait enterrée elle est
finalement bien de retour la fameuse
concertation sur la réforme des
retraites
j'ai toujours tenu un langage de vérité
oui notre système est injuste
avec quarante deux régimes différents il
entretient des inégalités majeur il
faudra aller vers plus de simplicité
pour plus de justice
j'ai entendu les débats sur le moment
faut-il faire cette réforme dès ce mois
de juillet à la rentrée ou bien plus
tard alors si je demande aux
gouvernements de jean castex de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
sur ce sujet dès la rentrée je ne
lancerai pas cette réforme tant que
l'épidémie ne sera pas sous contrôle et
la reprise bien n'assurons pas de
calendrier précis donc puisque
l'épidémie devrait selon toute
vraisemblance perdurer jusqu'à au moins
2020 tu de la réforme pourrait même être
renvoyée au prochain mandat présidentiel
une chose est sûre emmanuel macron
évoque clairement le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite
pourtant ce n'est pas ce qu'il prévoyait
dans son programme en 2017
c'est même exactement le contraire de ce
qu'il avait promis
deux ans après son élection en avril
le président de la république était
encore à peu près sur la même ligne
est ce qu'il faut reculer l'âge légal
qui est aujourd'hui à 62 ans
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas pour
deux raisons la première est un peu
direct c'est que me suis engagé à ne pas
le faire
et c'est quand même mieux sur un sujet
aussi important de faire ce qu'on a dit
par contre travailler plus ça peut se
faire d'une autre manière c'est
d'allonger la durée de cotisation est de
laisser le libre choix
ce qui est d'ailleurs au coeur du projet
qui est porté par jean paul delevoye en
juillet de la même année jean paul
delevoye au commissaire à la réforme des
retraites rende est justement son
rapport la question de l'âge pivot y
étaient posées l'inquiétude grandissait
du côté des syndicats et les
manifestations s'étaient enchaînés
[Musique]
début mars 2020 le gouvernement a
finalement utilisé l'article 49-3 pour
faire passer sans vote son texte sur la
réforme en première lecture à
l'assemblée
vivre mais la pandémie de coronavirus
est passée par là mettant à l'arrêt
l'agenda du gouvernement fillon en
déplacement dans le département du lot
les 2 et 3 juin dernier emmanuel macron
a rallumé la mèche en évoquant les
décisions difficiles à venir qui l'a
confirmé lors de son allocution ce lundi
soir le président de la république
n'écoute que lui il parle de
concertation sur les retraites mais il
annonce déjà qu'il faudra travailler
plus qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
aille discuter avec le gouvernement
mais l'agenda social du président ne
s'arrête pas là et les syndicats vont
devoir discuter d'un autre sujet avec le
gouvernement car si les dates de la
réforme des retraites reste flou la
réforme de l'assurance chômage sera elle
je cite pleinement mises en oeuvre dès
le 1er octobre